in January Teresa mace breaks that deal
was crushed by 230 votes last week it
was defeated by 149 so she still needs
75 MPs to change their minds and back
her deal if it's going to get through
well our next guest quit the cabinet so
that she could vote against the deal but
what she now changed her mind
estimate fate thank you very much for
being with us morning so are you going
to be voting for Teresa Mays Dale yes
because they hole the rules have all
changed before last week there was the
choice of this deal or no deal and
woodall stood on a manifesto and I
believe that no deal was better than a
bad deal and I still believe Teresa Mays
deal is a bad deal but after the votes
in the House last week that isn't the
option facing us anymore
No Deal has been removed the article 50
will be extended the date has removed so
the choice before us is this deal or no
brexit whatsoever and to not have brexit
you go against the Democratic vote of
the people
so government and Parliament have
connived to fundamentally undermine
brexit at the same time I'm just trying
to get my head around this you just said
that Teresa may still it's a bad deal
yes you literally resigned from cabinet
so you could vote against it and now
you're gonna change your mind on it
because as I said the votes before us
are very different when I resigned there
was still a chance to a get a better
deal because no deal was on the table
which is your negotiating strategy or
there would be no deal which is what we
said what we stood on our party
manifesto however last week the
government Teresa made the government
and Parliament conspired to take no deal
off the table so the choice before us
now is this deal her bad deal remains a
bad deal or no brakes at whatsoever when
a condition in which you could get
another tail no because she's taken no
deal off the table so if that was part
of your negotiating strategy is anybody
who does negotiations no she's taken
that off she's absolutely weakened her
hand so that is what were left with
those are the choices
that lay before us and I as somebody who
does believe in brexit obviously most of
Parliament doesn't we've still got 75%
of
MPs in the house who don't believe in
brexit have never reconciled with what
the Democratic vote of the people is so
if you actually want to stand up for
democracy stand up for brexit we will
then be forced holding our nose this is
not a position I'd want to be in it
certainly wouldn't be a position I'd
expect for the prime minister who has
said over a hundred times we will not
delay the date and she marched through
and has delayed the date and equally
stood on a manifesto that said No Deal
was better than a bad deal and all of
that changed last week in the house so
how many other conservative practices do
you think are in the same position as
you prepared to hold their noses and
vote for this deal well you said the key
word theirs they are brexit ears so they
know not only are they brexit ears they
are Democrats so a we believe in the
people in the vote and too we believe in
brexit and so what we're going to have
to do now is as I say holding our nose
vote for it and then look at Blanchett
being a stage process well there will be
various groupings of people so there
will be people who will say I will vote
for it because we believe brexit there
will be a cohort who of course will wait
for the DUP what are they going to do
because of course this is about the
Union as well and there will be some
people that will say absolutely not you
know we have been betrayed and we won't
come out but this is where you've got to
say do you stay on total purity and then
lose brexit altogether or are we going
to go for brexit in my view now would be
brexit will have to be in a multi-stage
process it's not a one decision
it will now be and the next phase is
very important for brexit so a rough
estimate at the people who could be
persuaded I know you said that there's
these three groups we know that there's
some who whatever happens I'm not going
to break the deal how many do you think
could be persuaded is it enough to get a
deal over the not nine what you said at
the top of the show I believe is still
the case to get the brexit or this deal
over the line would require Labour MPs
as well it will need other people and
not just conservatives yes and you've
spoken quite disparagingly about
some Romanian if you like it in in
Parliament and but at the same time they
voted for the deal it's the people such
as yourselves who voted against the deal
before which is the reason that we're
having the delay in the first place so
they're not really trying to frustrate
the will of the people are they no they
were trying to have a very soft brexit
they were also pushing for a second
referendum very I have Tory's amazed
brexit they're trying to actually make
it happen which on our party manifesto
is a bad deal as we know and we always
said no deal was better than the bad
deal most of us wanted and as I said
when I was last on the show that Teresa
made could have gone back she could have
removed the backstop and she could have
said this 39 billion is not paid for
nothing but actually get a free trade
agreement with her by people not
pursuing that line to get what was best
for the country they have left us with
the bad deal and hence brexit now will
have to be on a staged sort of process
to get out and what people will be
asking for is those feeble negotiators
to go because they cannot take us
forward to the next stage and because
there has been a weakening of the first
stage the withdraw rule the next stage
which is our future agreement is like a
much stiffer hill to climb
because what should have been an easier
part as I said through frustration via
government through the collapse of
collective responsibility through the
collapse of discipline within the party
machinery and basically MPs not wanting
the will of the people to succeed we
have now got to have a very difficult
second stage to get the future deal you
said that some of the feeble negotiators
in your word should go Absalom clued to
resume at for the time being it has to
be the team that is doing the core
negotiating it will also have to be to
get discipline back within a cabinet
people is led by the Prime Minister that
and it is led by the Prime Minister so
she will have to decide what she is
going to do but there will be calls for
her now because of what she did last
week which remember she said over a
hundred times that we would be leaving
come what
on the 29th of March and then she and
the team walked through a lobby
extending that date she has made life
very difficult for south and had cabinet
ministers by defying collective
responsibility have made life very
difficult for the Prime Minister and
that's what now she's got to look at how
she got disciplined in the government
would it help her deal to get through if
she laid out a timetable for when she's
going to quit that's what some are
suggesting and she will have to think
about that herself as I said she's got
to look at the fact when collective
responsibility collapses like that who
is the voice of government the
government should only have one voice so
the country knows what we stand for
so the world knows what we stand for so
when you have your team not abiding by
that and not doing the honorable thing I
didn't affirmation of quit that they
should have resigned and really they are
making the Prime Minister's position
very dubious her cabinet is doing that
to her I just wanted to have a look at
something you told me last time your
leave the program this is this is what
you said about running for leadership if
people ask me then of course should give
it serious concern and do it if people
ask me so have people been asking you
well they might have done but we're not
there yet you'd have to wait until there
is a leadership challenge or if there is
a leadership bids coming forward and
then again I would wait to see if people
mean it because there's a difference
between saying it when it's a
hypothetical to them saying it when it's
actually happening and if there were
enough people who supported me if it
seemed there was a reasonable chance I
would and if there weren't because
people who might have said it might not
then follow through and if there wasn't
I wouldn't stand for it now but it
sounds like it's something you're
seriously considering if people felt I
could and they wanted to back me I would
and as I said if they don't I wouldn't
okay that's my faith thank you very much
thank you